[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle est chiante pour essayer laisse
toujours près de mille cas quatre chiens
bonsoir je suis très heureuse et très
émue de présenter cette cérémonie des
césars 2021 qui célèbrent l'année 2020
2020 alors 2020 arrive un virus pardon
une virus l'aco vide
en fait non au début on l'a appelée
locaux vides mais quand on a compris que
ce serait très très long et très très
chiant on l'a mis au fait mine
donc là qu'ovide cette [ __ ] ça tue
surtout les vieux et c'est très triste
on reviendra pas là-dessus
un vieux qui meurt c'est une
bibliothèque qui brûle comme on dit en
afrique
enfin ça c'était avant qu'andy crunch
donc ça tue les vieux et les gros mais
comme on dit en afrique c'est quoi un
gros mais bon on est en france on n'est
pas en afrique n'est pas menée en france
comme ça tu surtout les vieux on a
enfermé les jeunes et fermer les cinémas
les théâtres les musées et interdit les
concerts pour ouvrir les églises car on
est un pays laïc pour que les vieux qui
ont eu le droit de sortir de l'ehpad à
noël ayala metz puisqu'on est un pays
laïc
et comme dieu merci les salles de
spectacles étaient fermés il y avait
moins de flux de gens donc on a pu
organiser des gros flux dans les grands
magasins et les centres commerciaux pour
qu'on puisse offrir à noël des trucs
qu'on a déjà
pour pouvoir les revendre le lendemain
sur ebay parce qu amazon y en a marre ça
pollue tout ça pour soutenir le
personnel soignant et pour qui est du
monde en réa parce que quoi de plus
triste qu'un lit vide c'est comme une
salle vie pour un artiste mais dieu
merci les salles de spectacles étaient
fermés donc elle risquait pas d'être
vide ou pas assez rempli parce que c'est
vrai l'art quand c'est pas rentable
ça fait chier voilà ça c'est 2020
ouais mais bon
car les points on est moins en colère
bon alors il ya quand même une question
qui s'est posée pourquoi faire les
césars cette année une année de cinéma
sont sales et sans public est un public
sans film pourquoi s'acharner faire
cette cérémonie devant une salle quasi
vide
bouleversant pathétique acte de
résistance
tout ce qui dégrade la culture raccourci
les chemins qui mènent à la servitude
albert camus nianing est une plante
verte elle va pas au cinéma et ses
feuilles à s'épanouissent quand même et
les abeilles elles font pas du solfège
donc calmos les artistes essentiel ben
oui mais alors pourquoi faire les césar
on a réfléchi on n'a pas trouvé
et c'est pour ça qu'on s'est dit que
c'était essentiel
et puis il ya quand même eu des beaux
films cette année six mois mais comme
non pas moins beau moins nombreux donc
faire les césars ou ne pas faire les
césars bas c'est compliqué sim est mort
le 27 décembre
est ce qu'on fait quand même la galette
le 6 janvier et si la mariée sus le
témoin qu'est-ce qu'on fait des dragées
c'est compliqué et marc on est là et on
est heureux d'être là et puis soyons
justes le gouvernement il a pas rien
fait il ya des aides et la ministre non
plus elle a pas rien fait madame
bachelot vous sortez un livre en pré
vente sur amazon 18 euros ma vie en rose
dans laquelle vous donnez votre recette
de pâtes au gorgonzola vous avez
vraiment les petits trucs pour trouver
du réconfort pour traverser les crises
c'est réconfortant le gorgonzola merci
pour ça mais en interview chez
delahousse vous dit
le gorgonzola ça sera très bien et là je
vous père madame le ministre et je perds
confiance en vous parce que oui oui le
goff non le parmesan oui le gorgonzola
non ce ne sera pas le gorgonzola et que
faire quand on n'a plus confiance en son
ministre de tutelle
à l'heure où se joue l'avenir du cinéma
de l'exception culturelle française
allez on arrête avec ces polémiques
vaines et ont fait les césars quoi qu'il
en coûte
c'est bizarre j'ai des jets des éléments
de langage du gouvernement dans la
bouche
j'espère que c'est pas le vaccin oui je
me suis fait vacciner avant tout le
monde parce que présenter les césar
c'est considéré comme une comorbidité
professionnels
quoi oui à temps a tourné parfois
attendant on me dit que une crotte ça
fait pas très césar mais même si on la
bombe en doré d'accord j'en attends
merde pour tout à l'heure alors il n'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi moi pour présenter
les césar pourquoi pas un soignant pour
leur rendre hommage
et bien parce que les césars ça se
présente pas en crocs voilà pourquoi
mais pourquoi moi cinq nominations 0
césar c'est quand même un peu sadiques
de me le proposait et c'est carrément
maso d'accepter mais bon je suis actrice
donc en même temps j'ai un respect moi
même assez limité mais c'est maso c'est
comme avoir une pharmacienne à la
culture en pleine pandémie mais
franchement je dis ça mais en fait ouais
je le vis très bien ne pas gagner
enfin très bien disons que il ya pire
eric toledano toledano le réalisateur
n'en pousse à le sens de la fête
hors norme trente neuf nominations un
césar c'est nul taux de réussite nul
et pourtant ça n'empêche pas d'être vice
président de l'académie michel piccoli 0
césar ça n'empêche pas d'être mort
est ce que michel piccoli sera toujours
vivant
s'il avait eu un césar non je crois pas
sinon lui en aurait donné un direct non
je crois que le césar ça sert à rien ce
qui convient enfin non ce qui est
important c'est d'être nous mais enfin
ça c'est ce qui convient de dire mais
bon ce soir et aura rien à dire il y
aura pas à faire bonne figure cette
année quelques vides n'y a pas
d'acheteurs cette année c'est un césar
et au lit mais on a été super seul
réjouissons-nous d'être ensemble et on
va se célébrer ouais et on va faire nous
mêmes parce que si on ne fait pas nous
mêmes qui le fera certainement pas les
soignants ils ont pris goût aux
applaudissements nous un mail où ils
demandent des revalorisations de
salaires pourquoi pas une augmentation
non oui on va on va se célébrer avant de
vous retrouver moi je rêve de ça je rêve
de salle
je pense à ceux qui s'ennuient mais je
pense à ceux aussi à que ce qui se
disait
r je pense à ceux qui vont en sage je
pense à ceux qui ont des salles je rêve
de grand écran avec plein de gens devant
je veux rire avec des inconnus je peux
pleurer avec des inconnus je couchais
avec des inconnus mais célèbre disons
des gens célèbres que j'ai pas encore
rencontré ouais ça manque à creuser même
au popcorn et nous manque
vous nous avez manqué bon c'est un peu
démago de dire ça parce que vous ça
n'existe pas vous enfin on se connaît
pas on n'est pas amis on se manque pas
mais disons que votre valorisante et
narcisse e-sante approbation en tant que
groupe nous a manqué et pu way
et puis ok vous savez peut-être rien
dire mais ni ça a du sens est ce qui
nous manque c'est ce qui nous lie c'est
les emmy les émotions qu'on vit ensemble
et puis nous font dire qu'on n'est pas
tout à fait seul et pour un truc
essentiel c'est déjà pas mal
alors ouais on a hâte de vous retrouver
[Applaudissements]